hello my name is Bryce Dallas Howard and
this is the wired autocomplete interview
I just watched Natalie Portman and Jude
Law do this this morning now I'm doing
it are these real things that people
googled yeah really
who is Bryce Dallas Howard who is she
she's a woman that's who she is
Bryce House Howard is a 37 year old
woman soon to be 38 mother of two whose
Bryce Dallas Howard husband Seth Gabel
he's awesome
I love him I do we met at NYU I kind of
stalked him and it worked out so let
that be a lesson who are Bryce Dallas
Howard parents I'm assuming yes my dad
is named Ronald William Howard and my
mother is named Cheryl Allie Howard but
she was born as Cheryl day Allie and
then she married my dad became Cheryl
Allie Howard who does Bryce Dallas
Howard look like well I'll let you guys
determine that I think you have some
opinions on the matter who is Bryce
Dallas Howard in spider-man 3 I'm Gwen
Stacy in spider-man 3 which was very
very very fun I got to dye my hair
blonde had to do it like every 10 days
because I would have red roots which was
really weird but yes still got to be
gwen stacy which I absolutely loved
Bryce Dallas Howard okay can Bryce
Dallas Howard sing oh that wasn't
actually amazing or anything but I'm a
tiny bit Kim Bryce Dallas Howard can
Bryce Dallas Howard blonde little-known
fact when I was Gwen Stacy there was a
big debate beforehand as to whether or
not I would be able to look like a
blonde one of the producers called
multiple directors that I worked with to
ask them that very question why is Bryce
Dallas Howard named Dallas
it's where I was conceived I used
grandparents names for my children's
middle names let's just be clear about
what I think is appropriate and what I
think is inappropriate okay did Bryce
Dallas Howard change her name so when I
was first at school and I was studying
acting and and when I was starting to
work professionally I didn't write down
Howard and stuff like that I just had
Bryce Dallas because I was a little
insecure and um but then that was
ridiculous actually was really it was
kind of intense one day my parents legit
asked me they were like are you not
proud to come from our family it's like
boom that's him Bryce Dallas Howard cry
on command I don't know should we test
it out we should test it out okay so I'm
gonna try to cry and command so it's not
something that takes a tremendous amount
of effort basically what happens is as
I'm talking I just let myself like lift
my soft pallet it gets myself like my
voice starts to tremble a little bit
it's purely technical it's not at all
something that I'm feeling I'm not
feeling upset right now like whatsoever
but it's just you know it looks like I'm
getting really upset but I'm not and so
ya know I can definitely definitely
definitely without question anytime you
want me to
[Laughter]
I'm like I have one special skill what
Bryce Dallas Howard oh that's what the
Natalie one was it was like what what
Bryce Dallas Howard what is Bryce Dallas
Howard in Oh what is bar sauce Howard in
while I'm wearing a Wolford turtleneck
um what is it 7-7
from mankind I'm really into fashion
what am i I'm in some movies I'm in some
movies
what is Bryce Dallas Howard Zodiac
Pisces Aries rising Capricorn moon which
is the same exact as my dad my dad is
also Pisces Aries rising Capricorn moon
out of the 12 houses astrological houses
we are the same in 11 out of those 12
it's so strange
what does bryce house what does bryce
dallas howard look like I look like
Pippi Longstocking is what I look like
okay what color is Bryce Dallas Howard
hair this color this is my natural color
I used to make it look redder but now I
don't what episode black mirror Bryce
Dallas Howard in I would like you guys
to know that that is not a properly
written sentence I think the question
really should be what episode of black
mirror is Bryce Dallas Howard in and the
answer that would be nosedive season 3
it's terrifying it's absolutely
terrifying
it's like um prophetic you know it's our
future kind of but um yeah it's also
terrifying is Bryce Dallas Howard
related to Ron Howard I am related to
Ron Howard he's my father
is Bryce Dallas Howard married happily
I've been married Seth and I Gables my
husband and we've been together for
almost in February it'll be 18 years and
we've been married for June 2006 that's
how long we married what is that 12
years 13 12 12 12 years is
bryce dallas howard vegan i was vegan i
was vegan for three and a half years but
I am no longer vegan it's Bryce Dallas
Howard related to Jessica Chastain
unfortunately no I'm not but but we look
alike I which I love because I'm Jess is
awesome
does Bryce house Herod have siblings I
do I do I have two sisters named Paige
and Jocelyn they are four years younger
than me and then I have a brother named
Reid and he is six years younger than me
and he is about to become a father soon
which is exciting what I can deduce from
the the things that people are googling
about is that people actually don't
really know about me
those are pretty general questions I
hope I've answered them for you here
today there were no deep questions nope